Ihsan Abdel
Karim, I am in a border area on Basan al-Kabira,
Sharqan Yunus, and we were informed by the occupation army that it had
invaded the area. Knowing that none of us are
resistance fighters, nor are my brothers resistant, nor is anyone in Al
Ain. We sat with my aunt and from my aunt’s house. We
moved to the schools to target the homes of
my aunt’s neighbourhood, and currently we are in
Care C Dive Agency Schools: There are approximately 14 families other than children who
are there if one person falls ill almost all the time. The
infection spreads, most of the time, if I find water in the first place. The agency provides it to some patients, not all patients,
but they know my condition because I am kidney disease, so they tried to
provide me with one glove a day, so I can wash it for three
days.  Almost every week, day after day, I
used to come to my appointment normally, but since the
war, I came an hour after my appointment.
[Music]
Three machines stopped due to the lack of
powder. Unfortunately, we wait for four or
five to wash, and
those who are not present in Khan Yunis, located in the
north, come to me.  In the area of ​​Khan Yunis, in order to do the
washing for them, the washing hours became two and a
half hours so that we have room
for others, knowing that it is not enough and we get tired
and sometimes we go back to the emergency room also where there is room for us to
wash because of the large number here. The
centers we have in Khan Yunis are the
only center, the Nasser Medical Complex that has  It is the
Hind Al-Daghma Center, which has been built for approximately
two years and has a lot of pressure on it. We have one in the
south of the Gaza Strip in Rafah. Then they cannot move,
of course, because of the bombing that is taking place and the first aid is not
enough to get there. He asked the world: We love
peace, we need wars. Enough of what happened to us, but this
war has
reached us.  50 years have passed, unfortunately